ni deux pôles infrastructures
vieillissantes viaduc endommagés bien
des québécois dénonce l'état actuel du
réseau routier
ces désastres c'est vrai j'y ai tout
dégât vaste champ métropolitaine sont
aux mains remplies querrien qui je suis
cette catastrophe vers loto-québec ya
pas d'aveu
mauvaise nouvelle pour les
automobilistes les routes vont se
dégrader encore plus c'est du moins la
conclusion d'un rapport d'experts
indépendants commandée par québec
selon ces experts le ministère des
transports n'est pas en position
d'effectuer annuellement un volume
suffisant de travaux pour empêcher que
l'état du réseau routier et des
structures ne se détériore dans les
prochaines années de 2015 à 2019 le
déficit d'entretien du réseau routier
est passée de 11,8 milliards à 16,4
milliards
un bond de 40% qu'on a toujours
l'impression de rouler sur des routes en
mauvais état mais le pire est à venir
l'association professionnelle des
ingénieurs du gouvernement du québec se
veut plus alarmiste encore elle craint
une catastrophe comme celle de
l'effondrement du viaduc de la concorde
c'est juste d'avoir une vue à moyen
terme de ont sauvé - au chantier en
espèces - nos structures et avec des
infrastructures qui se détériore d'année
en année il y avait les ingrédients pour
une catastrophe c'est irresponsable de
laisser sous entendre qu'ils pourraient
avoir des problématiques avec certaines
de nos structures et tous le ministre
des transports françois bonnardel
souligne que des sommes importantes ont
été investis dans le réseau routier
depuis l'arrivée de son gouvernement
mais pour marc andré martin il faut
faire plus on a un problème avec l'
expertise à l'inter on a besoin d'aller
chercher des ingénieurs chevronnés avec
un fort savoir-faire de terrain pour
être en mesure de payer le juste prix
on a un défi d'embauché ou de rétention
du côté des ingénieurs des machines à
mon collègue du conseil du trésor revoir
le processus d'embauché
malgré tout le ministre assure qu'il est
faisable d'entretenir les routes tout en
lançant de nouveaux grands projets
routiers ici mariage cousineau radio
canada
montréal